making my favorite I ain't going to
lie what's up y' it's your boy CJ y'all
used to see me on this field but I'm
trying to see what the tailgate scene is
about a lot of love out here for people
so I appreciate it it's cool man it's
not something I want to do I want to go
play a lemonade first buy this some
fire my guys be hting though what time
is it 9:00 in the morning 10:14 I Ain no
barbecue or no 10:14 but looks good
though he caught that easy it's for noon
games when it's like you need a good
breakfast thank you cuz I went to the
another spot and they have barbecue you
can have just bacon bacon my favorite I
ain't going to lie F
too some brisky that's brisky right
there okay wi okay my preference of a
tailgate I like this type of stuff but I
couldn't eat none of this in the morning
so I would prefer like more breakfast uh
for like a night game this one would be
perfect that's cool I ain't never got to
do something like so regular I guess you
would say but n it's dope